скажи чесно Як ти мені дуже боляче Я
плачу на сьогодні бачила
інтерв'ю з чоловіком якого загинула
дружина двоє дітей двоє онуків
кожна така естерика вона призводить до
темряви всередині і знесилення оцю білья
навчилася трансформувати в творчість це
теж мене дуже лікує зверне увагу на руки
стисни свої кулаки Зачекай 7-10 секунд
після чого розслабіг секунд на 15-20
тепер напружуся тіло так само на кілька
секунд і знову Розслабся відчуй чи не
залишилося напруженими окремі м'язи Якщо
так то попрацюй конкретно над ними а
тепер уяви тепло хвилю релаксу щоб
повільно розливається усім тілом дуде цю
техніку в свою аптечку самодопомоги